today's video is brought to you by
athletic greens and it's wonderful daily
blend of vitamins and minerals ag-1 by
athletic greens is a comprehensive
all-in-one greens powder engineered to
fill the nutritional gaps in your diet
and support your body's nutritional
needs across four pillars of health gut
health immune support energy and
recovery it's packed with 75 vitamins
and minerals and whole food sourced
ingredients combining the perfect amount
of micronutrients absorption and taste
to jump start your daily routine you'd
be hard-pressed to find a more
comprehensive powder supplement on the
market right now now as you guys know
i'm not exactly a fitness youtuber but i
do like to eat right and take care of
myself i also know i don't always eat
right so 81 definitely fills those gaps
for me what you do is you take one scoop
from the provided jar you put it in
the provided bottle and i take it in the
morning i do it with my coffee and it
tastes great
but somehow tastes healthy at the same
time
and i just feel it gives me a bit of a
sustained boost of energy throughout the
day which is nice plus age one is gluten
free dairy free paleo vegan keto low
allergen and low calorie less than one
gram of sugar per serving ag-1 is the
perfect dietary support regimen so if
this sounds like the supplement that
you've been looking for then you can
grab your own immunity bundle which
contains
one year supply of vitamin d plus five
individual travel packs for free with
your first purchase at
athleticgreens.com forward slash
biographics again year supply of vitamin
d five travel packs for free at athletic
greens.com forward slash biographics or
just click the link in the description
below and now today's video
it was an era of hope that soon
descended into agony in 1960 belgian
congo was at the head of a wave of
decolonization sweeping africa after
generations of exploitation this
gigantic nation larger than alaska and
california combined was free of the yoke
of european rule determined to forge its
own destiny for a handful of months that
shining future looked to be within reach
but then it slipped through everyone's
fingers instead the congo found itself
being squeezed lifeless in the iron grip
of a brutal dictator a leader more
corrupt than nearly any other in his era
his name was mabutu sesoseko and he
would single-handedly crush his nation's
dreams a former journalist heard army
officer mabutu had started out as one of
the good guys friends with patrice
lumumba a advocate for independence a
firm believer in helping the people how
he got from there to the depths of
kleptocracy is a tale of hubris and
tragedy a tale that biographics
is exploring today
on the depressing top 10 list of nations
you definitely don't want to get
colonized by the number one spot surely
goes to belgium in 1876 king leopold ii
took a gigantic swath of africa as his
own personal property turning its lush
forests into the heart of darkness
decades of enslavement murder and
mutilation followed as the belgian king
pillaged the land although his own
government eventually stripped him of
his possession in 1908 the damage had
already been done it was into this
wounded brutalized place that mabutu
seseko would be born coming into the
world on 14th of october 1930 joseph de
ceremotu as he was originally known
started his life weighed down by
disadvantages for one thing he was born
out of wedlock an unexpected son barely
acknowledged by his father for another
he grew up in what can only be described
as the arse end of nowhere a village so
remote that it didn't even appear on
maps yet his greatest disadvantage was
something far more intrinsic mabuta you
see was born black in a place that was
still under europe's thumb the belgian
congo that had replaced leopold's
atrocity exhibition may have been a step
up from the king's regime
but it was still racist as hell all the
good jobs all the important postings
were held by whites despite this being
their native land locals could only
dream of shattering that bulletproof
glass ceiling but while this shameful
setup would ignite a fire and guys like
patrice lumumba a desire to fight for
independence mabutu's way of dealing
with it was more nuanced for the first
30 years of his life booty would be very
much in the if you can't beat em join em
camp thanks to a french education at the
hands of belgium missionaries the young
man was eventually able to leave his
remote village and travel to the capital
leopoldville there he began a career in
colonial service joining the force
public and rising to the rank of
sergeant one of the highest ranks
available to black people but it would
be his parallel career as a journalist
that really made him interesting to the
belgians while working as a reporter in
leopoldville mabutu made contact with
the pro-independence movement by now it
was the mid-1950s and no one could
ignore the wave of decolonization
sweeping the world in belgium congo's a
guy riding the crest of this wave was
patrice lumumba a firebrand left-wing
nationalist he was pretty sure the
congolese could rule themselves more
effectively than dudes who thought
mayonnaise with fries was a legitimate
snack food as he reported on him mabutu
got to know lumumba better than almost
anyone he even joined the old man's
congolese national movement a pretty
radical step at the time yet there's
some suspicion today that mabutu was not
quite as radical as he seemed in 1959
the young man traveled to belgium to
study journalism in brussels at roughly
the same time that negotiations were
taking place on decolonization standing
in for lumumba when the activist was
briefly jailed it's thought mabutu may
have been passing information behind the
scenes to belgian intelligence an asset
for the colonials even as he was
publicly pushing the cause of
independence if that was the case though
it didn't do authorities in brussels
much good that same year
pro-independence riots paralyzed
leopoldville suddenly faced with the
prospect of a colony 77 times their size
becoming ungovernable the belgians
decided to run for the exit on june 30th
1960 belgian congo ceased to exist
becoming the independent nation of the
republic of the congo a name which
quickly had the word democratic attacked
on the front to avoid confusion with its
identically named northern neighbor was
the transfer of power patrice the member
was elevated to premiere with his
political rival joseph cassava boo
serving as president more importantly
for today's story though but the two
likewise entered government taking the
post of secretary of state for national
defence in effect giving him command to
the army little could lumumba or cassava
boo have known it but this well-spoken
journalist would soon turn out to be the
worst person for the job imaginable
[Music]
although it might have been independent
the word stable would not have been
anyone's choice to describe congo in
1960. just days after colonial rule
ended a mutiny broke out in the army
against the white officers one mabutu
only managed to put down through the
hasty distribution of bribes around the
same time a civil war erupted as the
wealthy province of kadanga tried to
split off under leader moist to chambe
and form an independent state on top of
that lumumba and cassava boo began
fighting for control of the government a
power struggle that threatened to
destabilize the entire region into this
rapidly developing dumpster fire came
the geopolitical gas canister
known as the cia 1960 of course was the
height of the cold war the cuban missile
crisis was just two years away and shady
government types and suits were super
jumpy about the idea of the soviet union
picking up allies anywhere in the world
so when the leftist lumumba asked moscow
for help putting down a rebellion in
katanga it was tantamount to signing his
own death warrant to this day many
suspect the cia's weapon of choice was
mabutu by september 1960 the former
journalist held perhaps one of the only
solid power bases in the country an army
paid with donated american money on the
14th mabuta used that armed power base
to launch a coup removing both lumumba
and kassababu from their posts but only
one of them would feel the full force of
mabutu's wrath after a long stand
offered a u.n compound lumumba was
captured trying to escape on november
27th beaten tortured the independence
leader was at last flown to katanga and
given as a gift to boyce to chamber the
rebel commander made sure he was never
seen again while this was the end of
lumumba though it wasn't quite the end
of a semi-democratic congo with lumumba
dead and the soviet threat neutralized
mubutu stepped back from his coup
kassavabu returns as civilian leader and
the army man slunk back to his base
apparently one of the reasons was the
cia's unwillingness to back a strong man
that it regarded as weak with his
refined tastes bookish air and habit of
indecision babutu just wasn't a guy
anyone could see dictating anything one
american diplomat derided him as a black
hamlet after the shakespearean character
who famously spends five acts doing
nothing but that's the thing about
dictators they come in all sorts of
flavors while some like adolf hitler are
clearly megalomaniacs by the time they
reach power others only show their true
colors well it's too late to stop them
the next couple of years passed in a
series of rolling crises with western
backing the government was able to
reintegrate katanga with moyes to chambe
even going on to become the congo's
prime minister but this just caused more
problems as cassava boo started clashing
with the new guy just as it clashed with
lumumba by 1965 their feud had become so
bitter that the government was
effectively paralyzed it was at this
point the mamutu pulled off his real
coup on november 24th 1965 the army
announced that democracy had been
suspended and all power temporarily
vested in mabutu's hands thanks to the
coup's echoes of 1960 everyone was all
like okay i guess we don't really need
to worry he gave us power back last time
right but mabuji's 1965 takeover would
be nothing like the last time in the
aftermath of his seizure of power babutu
had cassava boo placed under house
arrest and to chamber sent into exile
they both died in mysterious
circumstances not long after by then
though it was clear what was happening
blaming partisanship for congo's crisis
mabutu banned rival political factions
replacing the various parties with just
one the popular movement of the
revolution membership became mandatory
as was voting for it so when mubitu
called a democratic election to decide
his next move the results were
inevitable of all 20 million citizens
only 157 cars ballots against the party
itself a surprisingly large number given
there was literally no one else to vote
for just like that the era of democracy
in the democratic republic of the congo
was over with executive functions still
suspended in the nation now a one-party
state the ex-journalist at the head of
it was suddenly free to do
whatever he wanted and what mabutu
wanted was to build one of the nastiest
most flagrantly corrupt dictatorships
in all of history
[Music]
sometimes when we do these dictator
videos it can be hard to ascertain the
exact moment they went from in it for
the people to edit for themselves plus
also tons of insanity however there
exists no such gray area where mabutu
cesoseko is concerned as far as we can
tell he stepped onto the leadership
stage determined to act like a
megalomaniac or tyrant the tyrant part
became incredibly obvious incredibly
quickly mere months after taking power
mabutu had four government ministers
hanged in a sports stadium in front of
50 000 people while it's not so shocking
for the guy who willingly handed his old
friend lumumba over for a torture and
murder session it did mark a brutal new
step in congolese governance one that
would get more brutal as time went on
and torture and sexual violence became
tools of oppression nor was the
oppression merely physical like most
dictators mabutu was super keen for all
his subjects to think and act as he
wanted them to in his case that meant
forcing everyone to accept his ideology
of authenticity when you just skim the
basics authenticity sounds kind of
interesting arguing as it did against
simply recreating european systems in
the postcolonial era and instead looking
to a political heritage that was truly
african
but then you read what mabutu defined as
european and you realize it was mostly
just another excuse for keeping himself
in power according to authenticity
democracy was inherently european and an
african society should revolve around a
powerful chief with the chief's own
ostentatious wealth and power the sole
way of measuring the nation's health so
while for common folk authenticity meant
being banned from listening to foreign
music straighten their hair or using
christian names for mabutu it meant a
literal black check in his decades of
rule the congolese dictator signed over
so much of his nation's wealth to his
own pocket that by some counts he was
the most corrupt kleptocrat in history
now such rankings are always a little
dubious and there are other contenders
like sahato or ferdinand marcos but to
give you an idea of the eye-watering
embezzlement that mobutu was up to here
are just a few of the things that he
blew ungodly sums on always a man of
refined taste even in his journalist
days mabutu's dictator dedicated himself
to collecting expensive trophies that
meant a string of mansions around the
world and concord jets at his beck and
call to take him on shopping trips at
the drop of a leopard-skin hat nor did
he just use charted planes to transport
people in one particularly memorable
episode the dictator decided he wanted
to start keeping sheep on his ranch
uninterested in european breeds he
ordered one of his jets to make 32 round
trips to caracas in until as many as 5
000 venezuelan sheep had been brought
across the atlantic ostentatious all of
this was though it paled beside
gabadelite mabutu's ancestral home
gabalite had been an invisible village
when he was born place colonial
authorities didn't even bother including
on maps of the wild northern regions but
that wasn't auspicious enough for
mobutu's tastes so yet the whole town
torn down and rebuilt only now the mud
huts became marble villas the local
mission a luxury five-star hotel a vast
dam and hydroelectric power plant were
constructed just to ensure the lights
were always on when the leader visited
an airport was built with a runway big
enough for concords to take off from to
top it all off on the edges of the
expanding settlement babutu built
himself a palace one nicknamed the
versailles of the jungle a place stuffed
with old master paintings and vintage
french furniture where he could escape
the capital and sip pink champagne while
listening to classical music all the
while his already ravaged nation sank
deeper and deeper into poverty in this
era many referred to that nation as a
rich country of poor people alluding to
its vast mineral wealth wealth mabutu
personally siphoned off five billion
dollars from but such thievery was only
made possible by having friends
in some very high places
perhaps one of the most remarkable
things about mabutu was how open he was
about his sins in 1977 for example he
gave a speech nominally warning of the
evils of corruption but which
effectively doubled as a kind of advert
everything is for sale he declared
anything can be bought in our country
again this was dressed up as an
anti-corruption speech but those
listening caught the high-pitched tones
of the kleptocratic dog whistle with
bobot's nation rich in diamonds copper
and cobalt dozens of western firms were
more than happy to close their eyes to
his abuses in return for buying up those
resources who cared if their dollars
flowed straight into the tyrant's
pockets after all it's not like vastly
more powerful actors weren't interested
in backing babutu actors with the wealth
and technology of entire states at their
disposal by now the 1960s had given way
to the 1970s what had once been the
democratic republic of the congo had
been renamed zaire by mabutu who'd
likewise renamed himself mabutu seseko
kuku bendu wazabanga or to give him the
english version of his title the
all-powerful warrior who because of his
endurance and inflexible will to win
will go from conquest to conquest
leaving fire in his wake but while times
may have changed the cold war was
eternal with communist influence always
threatening to expand western powers
were permanently on the lookout for
bulwarks against marxism who cared if
those bulwarks were preposterous
dictators who ate the finest foods while
their countrymen starved so it was the
mabutu was able to stay in everyone's
good books courted by washington paris
and brussels in return for stamping out
the soviet flame in africa remarkably
this went well for the dictator even
when it went badly in 1975 zayer sent
troops across the border into angola to
stop a left-wing militia from taking the
capital only it turned out that
left-wing militia had serious cuban
training and was able to wipe the floor
with mabutu's troops and then seize
power yet even this debacle didn't dent
his foreign support when katanga erupted
in rebellion a couple of years later
french belgium moroccan troops all came
to his aid backed up by american
logistics so long as he was
anti-communist mabutu couldn't be
allowed to fall which is remarkable when
you consider just how uncapitalist so
many of his policies were 1973 for
example saw the advent of xyronization a
fancy word for expropriation and
nationalization of foreign-owned
businesses unfortunately it turned out
that those foreigners mostly pakistani
and belgium but greek and jewish too
were pretty good at business while the
cronies mabutu handed their property
over two weren't the result was a
general collapse of productivity which
in turn fed into the general economic
malaise and sense of decline a decline
that couldn't be halted even with absurd
stunts like movie paying muhammad ali
and george foreman five million dollars
each to take part in rumble in the
jungle in the renamed capital kinshasa
come the 1980s the one thing keeping the
nation economically afloat was high
copper prices prices high enough that
mobutu could pay off strong rivals and
keep his cronies in relative luxury not
that being a mabutu crony was much fun a
man who'd like to dominate people mabutu
was fond of sleeping with his
underling's wives both to humiliate them
and to show how powerful he was how he
could do anything and you just have to
smile and take it but no matter how
powerful he felt no matter how many
broadcasts from tv stations began with
an image of him descending from the
heavens mabutu was far from the
strongest force in his nation as the
1980s progressed the twin impersonal
forces of economics and history were
going to bend his regime to breaking
point and when it finally snapped it was
going to take a whole lot of people down
with it
vladimir putin infamously called the
breakup of the soviet union a tragedy
but while most georgians ukrainians
estonians and so on would probably
disagree it absolutely was a tragedy for
one man in africa with the cold war over
babutu ceso seiko suddenly found western
support for his regime drying up the
decade before the collapse of cop prices
and ballooning national debt had left
zaire effectively reliant on american
and european aid as long as washington
was still worried about the soviet
threat that aid kept coming but when the
ussr collapsed a whole bunch of
officials began to ask themselves why
they were throwing money at this corrupt
despot so in the early 1990s they
stopped in an effort to keep the money
tap on mabutu tried introducing
multi-party democracy but when that
resulted in a new prime minister that he
didn't like he suspended the guy after
just 12 days so the west stopped
financially backing him with nothing
else going for it what remained of
zaya's economy bottomed out in those
dark days inflation peaked at seven
thousand percent deadly riots repeatedly
swept the capital not that mabutu really
cared as the country descended the
dictatorship retreated to the luxury of
gabadolite there he drank imported
champagne and detained wealthy guests a
bizarre male caricature of marie
antoinette eating cake in the fake
versailles while everything went to hell
in the end though it wouldn't be turmoil
in his own nation that toppled mabutu
but a humanitarian disaster across the
border on april 6 1994 a plane carrying
rwanda's president juvenal habyar imana
was shot down over the capital kigali an
estinhutu habiyaramana was killed at a
time of extreme tensions between the
nation's hutu majority and tutsi
minority the very next day hutu
extremists stated by the government
began the systematic killing of tutsis
in what would become one of the 20th
century's worst genocides 800 000 people
would be killed in just 100 days in
neighboring zaire the effects would be
apocalyptic not that it looked like
rwanda was going to destabilize mobutu's
regime at first quite the opposite as
rwanda exploded former colonial powers
like france were desperate for regional
partners always ready to exploit a
crisis mabutu opens aye to paris
immediately turning himself back into a
darling of the west a status that only
increased when he agreed to host over a
million refugees the trouble was those
refugees weren't persecuted tootsies but
hutus including some hutus who had
helped direct the genocide by july the
4th 1994 the tutsi-led rwandan patriotic
front had fought its way into the
capital and toppled the government
fearing the coming backlash many hutus
had fled to zaire among them were
militias who now use mabutu's nation as
a staging ground for attacks on the rpf
but while booty may have been fine with
cross-border raids the rpf certainly
weren't and they would soon be more than
happy to take matters into their own
hands
mabutu seseko was in switzerland seeking
treatment for prostate cancer when he
got the call it was autumn of 1996 and
the dictator was miserably ill so
advanced was his cancer that had become
incontinent forcing him to wear diapers
so he wouldn't soil himself in another
universe it's all but certain the cancer
would have ended babutu's rule his grip
on power only loosening when he finally
died but not in this universe that day
mabutu could only listen in horror as he
heard the news that the rpf had crossed
into zaire worse they were backing a
brand new zyrian rebel group determined
to oust him a group receiving money and
weapons from a coalition of african
states that had wronged in the past
hoping to inspire his army to fight him
the old sick man returned home preparing
to face down the invaders but when he
got there he found far far too few
people willing to lay down their lives
for him over the following months the
rebels fought their way across the
congo's rivers and mountains along
isolated roads through dense forests by
may 1997 they'd reached kinshasa
terrified mabutu did as it always done
before and he begged the west for help
this time though the west wasn't
listening on may the 16th the diamobutu
boarded his plane and fled into exile in
a sign of how bad things have become his
own officers took pot shots at the craft
as it rose into the air the bullets
pinging off the hull yet the big
humiliation would be babutu's inability
to land initially heading for france the
plane was refused permission to enter
european airspace so mabutu instead flew
to togo whose own dictator had backed in
the past but he was allowed to stay
there just a handful of days before togo
also ordered him to leave and neither
the cia nor belgian intelligence who had
clandestinely served willing to help him
in the end the only nation that would
accept him was morocco it was here in a
hospital in the city of rabat that
mabutu spent the last months of his life
a disgraced cancer-ridden exile unable
to do anything as his palace was looted
as zaire was renamed the democratic
republic of the congo as his name was
scrubbed from history he didn't even get
the bitter satisfaction of watching the
nation descend into civil war without
him by the time the second congo war
started the dictator was no more mabutu
seseko died on september 7th 1997 at the
age of 66. he left behind a broken and
financially broke nation one with the
mineral wealth to be staggeringly rich
but instead trapped in a quagmire of
poverty and violence and while a legacy
of colonial exploitation certainly
hadn't helped mobutu's reign had only
made things a thousand times worse today
it's hard to truly grasp what an utter
disaster mabutu seseko
at independence his nation had been
wounded and ravaged yes but with a
possible bright future ahead of it one
embodied in the fiery national pride of
patrice lumumba but mabutu had helped
strangle that future killing number and
seizing power then plundering his nation
with the greed as vast as it was
self-defeating it's rare in modern
history to meet leaders who are
unequivocally good or bad a disastrous
president might do great humanitarian
work or a venerated prime minister might
tarnish his greatness with racism mabutu
seseko though falls into that special
category of people who simply made the
world a worse place who offered nothing
beyond narcissism and greed and
delivered both in abundance we can only
hope this will remain his epitaph
for centuries to come
[Music]